欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课。
第一个就是去选搜索指数是上涨的词。第二个就是少商家使用的词,也就是你的同行使用的人很少的关键词。第三个就是一定要用点击率大于零的关键词。为什么?因为我们到时候要打爆这款产品的时候一定会用直通车。用直通车的时候,如果你是点击率为零的词,很容易就会出现高曝光的情况。
或者是说高点击,但是没有循环的情况。这两种情况一定要提前的规避,否则你这里短期打爆,那你要付出的直通车的成本就会非常的大。所以提前规避好这些常规的错误,那么我们就能够接受更多的推广预算。选持标准一定要牢记这三个去选。那么接下来我们来具体看一下操作的流程。第一个就是
你要确定你的品类。这个我们前面已经讲了,先找到这个品类。品类找好了之后,就是根据这个品类的词根,在关键词搜索指数里面去查找。根据词根,找到一批关键词。找了之后我们去进行找男孩子。比如说像我们这种,你选了这个词,也选了这个词。下面还有很多
很多的关键词,在下面还有很多很多个,都是这种的,你看第一个是指数上涨,指数上涨的。商家用的少,商家用的少,看到吗?商家用的少,商家用的少,点击率,点击率都是大于0的。这类词,你要把三个指标找到,再根据这些词,你找到了
50个,或者甚至更多的上百个这种词。找到了这些词之后,你开始根据这些词,去选款。现在这个方向是反过来的,是根据词,去选
款。同时呢,这个款,一定要参考
当前同行,爆品的款式,一定按照这个逻辑去选。你才能够在
这么多有效的词里面,匹配上有效的款式,才能够获得后期的,打爆的概率就会更大。
不然的话,你词你是找的挺好的,但是你的款选的
很垃圾,那么是不是就
词品不匹配,买家跟这个款式的需求,就没那么迫切,所以说它就会导致你寻盘转化的问题,要么高,要么低,就这种情况。
开始就是进行标题的组合,标题的组合就按照我们前面所讲的方法,就可以了。
就把这些按照
搜索指数从左到右
往上提
往上增长
同时你要确定
核心的
结尾词
如果你是要组三到五个标题,那么就确定三到五个
然后在前面填补
具体的
产品关键词就可以了
最后面
通常来说
我们是这样操作的
一般发产品是同一款,可能会发1到5个链接
这个词取决于
你的关键词的总量多少,比如说你关键词比较少,那么发1到2个
如果你关键词非常非常非常的多,那么发3到5个链接
同一款
发3到5个链接
那么你可能是
推广的是可能是2到3款
2到3款,那么你组的标题可能就是
10到15个
链接是吧
10到15个链接一开始就把他们全部
加入到新品加速里面,一次性推15个链接。我这里15是基于你现在发的产品的数量
并不是代表是新品成长
新品加速就只推15个,而是基于你当前
组合标题的重量来做一个
选择的,这个数量的话还是可以再增加
但是前期你就根据这个逻辑去组
这些标题
看你的标题总量是多少,然后再进行推广
就可以了
那么这个就是我们
所说的
通过
查找蓝海的流量池
来进行组合标题去打爆
它是一个怎么样的逻辑呢
比如说它都是这些蓝海池都是这种上涨的,都是短期内上涨的
说明呢,它现在的竞争那么少,我是不是
我一开始组合,我马上就推广,是不是我
很可能就是用
很少的钱
就能够排在前面很好的位置
只要它排在我前面位置,我比别人早
早去推广
早发现这类词
比如说这些关键词,我就比同行积累的数据
多和快
那么我这个产品
的关键词就很快就占据了
前面的排名
很快就能够获得前面的自然排名
前期是推广,推广到一定程度,那么我数据那么好
那么它的自然排名自然而
而然的上涨了
你的整个的产品的成本
推广成本就会下降
所以这种方法是非常的
高
高效的
店铺里面或者是你的行业里面出现这种类型的词很多
那么我建议的话就是用这种方式去打造你的爆品
好了这节课我们就先讲到这里
如果你
的店铺当然符合这个方法
马上就用
键效非常的快